العمليات او التجهيزات التي خصصتها
السعوديه داخل هذا المقر كيف هي
الغرف ايضا عمليه تجهيز الوجبات ايضا
عمليه تجهيز الفندق هذا الفندق تحديدا
كباقي الفنادق الاخرى هو بفئه خمسه نجوم
هو مهيا هناك عدد من موظفين في الاسفل عند
الاستقبال هم مخصصين فقط من اجل تلبيه
احتياجات وتوفير مستلزمات ما يرغبه
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا بلدانهم عبر مطار
الملك عبد العزيز
تفضل هاني اعاده الصوره انقطعت نعم هذه
واحده من الغرف نعم هذه واحده من الغرف
الطبيعيه او الغرف التي خصصتها السعوديه
لكل شخص او لكل عائله هي موفره بهذا الحجم
بهذه المساحه كما نشاهدها ايضا الغرف هي
من قسمين قسم خاص بغرفه النوم قسم اخر
بالجلوس طبعا في هذا الفندق تحديدا نتحدث
عن اكثر من 400 شخص من جنسيات مختلفه هم
يسكنون في هذه في هذا الفندق هناك ايضا
العداد الاخرى التي تتجاوز الالفين
يسكنون في مقرات اخرى قريبه من هذا الفندق
هناك ايضا حافلات ايضا هناك كما ذكرت هناك
موظفين مختصون من اجل تلبيه احتياجات
ومستلزمات التي يحتاجونها هؤلاء الرعايه